today everyone woke up and bitcoin is
back over fifty thousand dollars it
means that bitcoin is now closer to a
hundred thousand dollars than it is to
zero
if we go ahead and we look we've got a
ton of data around why bitcoin is such
an incredible asset it is the apex
predator of financial markets first we
can see today that bitcoin over fifty
thousand dollars up a little over four
percent every single other asset that
you can consider
is basically
non-volatile in comparison volatility is
not good or bad if you are holding an
asset and it is volatile to the upside
that is a good thing if you are holding
an asset and it's volatile to the
downside that's a bad thing so
volatility on its own is not good or bad
it depends on how you are positioned in
the market
and so these other assets have a lack of
volatility you can see oil up 1.77
you can see gold up similar you can also
see that things like the euro and the
yen barely moving at all bitcoin happens
to move much much more and so therefore
over long periods of time if it
appreciates that volatility works in
your favor if we then go ahead and we
look at specific stats around the
bitcoin network itself today we sit just
under 950 billion dollars in market cap
bitcoin was launched january 3rd 2009
and in about 12 years we have gone all
the way up to 950 billion market cap
it's pretty impressive right now the
inflation rate is 1.78
the u.s dollar inflation rate on a cpi
basis is over five percent the core
inflation rate is over four percent and
so bitcoin's inflation rate is much much
more attractive than the legacy system
about 89.6
of all bitcoin has already been issued
of the 21 million total in the last 24
hours there was 18 billion dollars of
bitcoin that was settled on the
blockchain this is not exchange traded
volume simply on the blockchain in the
blocks of transactions there was 18
billion dollars there's been about seven
days total of over 20 billion dollars of
settlement that's ever occurred on the
bitcoin blockchain so very very high
rate of settlement happening right now
you also can see there's about seven
billion dollars of exchange traded
volume this is going on to places like
coinbase gemini blockfi etc and actually
buying and selling bitcoin there's over
1 million active addresses in the last
24 hours so whenever somebody says
nobody uses bitcoin well there was a
million people a million addresses that
used it yesterday on top of that the
bitcoin miners yesterday were paid
almost 46 million dollars as part of the
mining reward miners get paid through
two specific ways the first revenue
stream which makes up the majority of
their revenue is through the mining
reward that is the 900 bitcoin that came
into circulation yesterday on top of
that they also get transaction fees
transaction fees are a small percentage
of their revenue today but the thought
process is over time those will grow to
become larger and larger but yesterday
in the last 24 hours bitcoin miners made
almost 46 million dollars in top line
revenue and then we can see that bitcoin
is up 72 from the cycle low and it's
still trading at 22 below the all-time
high and if we go and we look over the
last 1 3 five and ten years what we can
see is that bitcoin has continued to
appreciate very rapidly it has
outperformed gold and the s p gold is
down eight percent over the last year
gold is down one percent over the last
nine years bitcoin's performance is
unlike anything that has ever happened
in financial markets before it is very
very special if we start to look at the
bitcoin price closing history by various
levels we can see that bitcoin over the
last year or so
has only traded above the current level
73 days in the history of bitcoin so if
you bought bitcoin 88.4
of days of bitcoin's life
you have more purchasing power today
than you did before so again i'm sorry
98
if you bought bitcoin 98
of days since bitcoin was created you
have more purchasing power today than
you ever have before and that's 73 days
above current price levels is all in
this year so anyone who has been a
long-term holder of bitcoin has been
able to protect their purchasing power
and actually increase it rather than if
you hold legacy assets you actually have
seen a depreciation or a devaluation of
that purchasing power if you go all the
way back to 30 000 price level we've
only ever spent 275 days of the entire
life cycle of bitcoin less than six
percent of the time above 30 000. so we
are in uncharted territory but what it
shows you is that if you are a long-term
holder of this asset historically it has
proven to be very very effective history
is not necessarily an indicator of
future performance but it is quite a
good
point to pay attention to and lastly we
have this idea of comparing bitcoin to
the various indexes and assets and what
you can see in this chart here is
comparing bitcoin gold the s p 500
nasdaq and treasuries if you look at
that roi of course bitcoin drastically
outperforming bitcoin up about 365
percent or so in the last year if you
look at something like gold it's down 8
percent if you look at the stock it's
just over 25
but what i'm most interested in this
chart here is if you go to the keger
cagr compound annual growth rate over
the 10-year period bitcoin has grown at
a
155 percent
compound annual growth rate that means
that every year on average over a
10-year period it's gone up 155 percent
and so when you compound 155 growth
every year for a decade you get the best
performing asset in the history of
financial markets if you compare that to
something like the s p 500 or nasdaq
those are both down under 20 and under
15
even gold being down just at .6
so bitcoin's performance is incredibly
dominant that is why we call it the apex
predator financial markets if you then
look at the sharpe ratio as well very
very high sharp ratios over a one and a
five year period um and when you think
about a sharp ratio that simply is
saying if you put this asset into a
portfolio when you compound the return
profile and you can uh compare the
correlation levels and the sharp ratios
bitcoin can do very special things for a
portfolio even if you only have a small
allocation and so we will continue to
watch this because we think that bitcoin
is going to become one of the most
important if not the most important
financial asset in the world and it's
important to remember that there is a
ton of market participants and trillions
of dollars that are all swirling around
in the financial market trying to find a
home and bitcoin is likely to continue
to suck up a lot of that value